من يوم خسرته لانتخابات الرئاسه في عام
2020 والسؤال الابراج راح يترشح ثاني ولا
لا طبعا عم نحكي عن الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب واللي من بعد شهور او
يمكن حتى سنوات من الاخذ والرد والتلميحات
والتصريحات اعلنها وكشفها صراحه
رئاسيا الانتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه 2014
امريكا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعلان ترامب في خطاب في منزله في
فلوريدا بعد اسبوع من الانتخابات النصفيه
الاعلان الكبير
الاتحاديه الامريكيه لتشكيل لجنه
رئيسا لامريكا 2420
من وقت خطابه حول العالم من ابرز ردود
الفعل بالطبع كان رد فعل الرئيس الامريكي
الحالي
رد في تغريده قال فيها انه ترامب خذل
البلاد ايام ما كان رئيس وارفق بالتغريده
فيديو بيعدد من وجهه نظر بعيدا طبعا كل
القرارات السيئه التي اخذها وعمل لها
ترامب
بس ردت فعل لافته اخرى على الاعلان جاءت
من داخل اسره ترامب نفسه تحديدا ابنته
ايفانكا اللي كانت بجانب والطوال لحمله
الاولى وخلال رئاستو كانت هي وزوجها جايه
كوشنر من كبار مستشعرين وكان برفقته
وبجانبه او كانوا الاثنين بجانب طوال
الوقت ايفانكا اصدرت بيان بعد اعلان
والدها اعلانات في انها راح تبتعد عن
السياسه وقالت في بيانها احب والدي كثيرا
لكن هذه المره اختار ان اعطي الاولويه
لابنائي والحياه الخاصه التي نحاول بناءها
كائله اضافت لا اخطط للانخراط بالسياسه
لكني مستمره في حب ودعم والدي وساقوم بذلك
دوما ولكن بعيدا عن عالم السياسي طبعا خبر
عدم دعم ايفانكا
وزوجته
كانت تتنقلته ايضا وسائل الاعلام من فتره
ولكن كان غير مؤكد حتى بيان الى كان هذا
اليوم اما زوجها كوشنر فتحتها هذه اللحظه
هو ملتزم الصمت ولم يصدر عنه شخصيا اي
موقف رسمي يوضح موقفه من ترشح حماه لا
ولايه جديده